right now
number 10 reject that Friday's big
statement with all those tax cuts and
all that additional borrowings 72
billion pounds extra borrowings until
April that quasi quality needs in order
to fund all those tax cuts number 10
reject that is the main reason for the
terminal that we've been seeing in the
markets and the emergency intervention
by the bank of everything it's quite
incredible I mean the uh Sterling was
falling guilts rates of borrowing costs
going up pretty much immediately after
that statement which happened on Friday
morning but number 10 do not accept that
on a cabinet minister today told me that
it was BS if you excuse the language
that there is a link between one and the
other they also say well the Situation's
getting much better because of the bank
of England intervention in any way this
is all because of what's going on
overseas I understand some in number 10
think this is primarily Sophie a
Communications problem and a problem
with how they've managed stakeholders
presumably uh the markets so there is a
sense
at the very center of government that
this isn't a crisis this isn't something
that requires a dramatic approach an
all-encompassing Focus they seem to be
taking it in their stride doing other
things concentrating on other issues as
we go along and we head towards
conservative conference and they don't
think they're to blame now I don't know
Tory MPS disagree with that quite a lot
of global Economic Institutions the
markets the global Banks disagree with
number 10. this is very serious so it
feels like there has been I guess a
certain amount of shock surprise since
what happened on Friday at both from the
markets but also from conservative MPS
should people be surprised
I think some of some of the surprise
bluntly is people not paying enough
attention we knew quite a lot of what
was going to happen on Friday well in
advance we also knew the warnings about
what would happen if they did what they
did on Friday and the consequences that
was the subject of the leadership
contest on the one side you had Liz
trust promising massive tax cuts funded
by borrowing all the way through and on
the other side her rival where she's
seen like all the way through was saying
if you do that you risk it run on the
pound and government borrowing costs
going up there could be a financial
crisis if you do that we've known that
for months so there's no point in
pretending that this is all some
dramatic shock yes Liz truss's uh mini
budget went further than we were
expecting on Friday although Christopher
is right to say that proportionately the
bits that we're most surprised about
didn't go it weren't the biggest costs
in that budget but conservative members
the 80 000 also people that decided who
on current prime minister is did so
having heard the warnings the expert
advice and deciding actively to reject
that and that's why we are where we are
today Sam thank you very much indeed